welcome back to piers morgan on censor
eco activists have become a regular
irritant on uk rose sitting in front of
traffic sometimes gluing themselves to
the tarmac i sympathize with their cause
but not the way they're going about it i
think it's dangerous and just winds
people up rather than bring them to
their calls and side but one such person
who did take them on was sharon speed
who'd just been banned from driving
after she nudged three insulin britain
activists with her car when they blocked
her on the school run here's what
happened
[Music]
move out of the way
joins me now along with liam norton from
insulate britain good evening to both of
you cherylin um when i watch that video
i just see i see a mum desperate to get
her kid to school on time i've got a 10
year old who i take to school but i walk
at a school you have to drive your son
you now can't do that when you look back
at what happened there describe your
frame of mind about what you encountered
and the way you reacted
janae what it was a really hard time
personally for me um i know more people
are aware of my bit of my background now
i just found it really stressful you
know it's early in the morning i'm
trying to get my sunscreen get to work
i've got personal things going on as
well i'm suffering with anxiety and i've
got these people in front of me stopping
me from going to where i needed to go
i just found it really difficult a
difficult it's really hard experience
for me
and when you then got dragged through
the courts you were banned from driving
for a year received a 240 pound fine you
were charged with assault although that
got dropped
i mean could you really believe that you
were suddenly being made to look like
the villain in this story
i mean i've been to caught three times
for this
um
i'm still shocked that i'm on a driving
ban i'll be honest i don't really think
that i deserve that i mean they did say
it was going to be careless driving
which meant i got points on my license
and a fan and i was happy you know to
accept that i understand that i did do
wrong you know and i take the
consequences but for someone who has no
previous convictions and you know not
even points my license i just felt like
that was a bit harsh and as a result you
now can't drive for a year you can't
take your son to football training he
trains all over london and essex you
can't help your mother with her shopping
and getting around
um it seems to me that you've ended up
being pretty harshly punished here when
in fact you were being prevented just
from going about your normal day
yeah yeah
all right well let's bring in liam
liam you represent insulate britain
i look at that video and i see a mum who
wants to get a kid to school on time you
want to you know protect the planet and
make it better for her son and at the
same time you want to stop him being
educated so people watch that and they
go why are you doing this why can't you
protest in a different way to literally
lying in front of cars to the point
where a young mum loses it and ends up
with a fine and everything else and not
being able to drive a boy around
yeah i mean i i agree with you it's that
it's it's not a good situation i i've
spoke to sherilyn about a month ago
and we had a really good conversation
she's still got misgivings about the
tactics that insulate britain were using
back then but she also said to me that
she didn't realize how bad this climate
crisis was for our 11 year old son and
that's a similar position to me like i'm
an electrician appears right i'm just a
normal bloke in 2018 i see the front
page of the paper and there was a
hundred academics including the
archbishop of canterbury who said that
it was morally justifiable to get
arrested because of how bad this climate
crisis was and they blocked bridges and
commentators like yourself were very
unhappy that people were blocking
bridges but that highlighted to me how
bad this crisis is and i still stand by
the justification for the fact that
public disruption is necessary because
we're looking at the absolute collapse
of
civilization
i actually have a lot of sympathy with
the calls that you're fighting right i
don't disagree with you about the threat
from climate change or global warming
right but what i disagree with you were
about the tactics because yeah insulate
britain you know you've had a case where
a man was trying to drive his mother to
hospital when she suffered a stroke
you know and
he believes the son that if you'd
actually
if you go to the hospital earlier she
would have recovered as a result she's
been left paralyzed you had insulated
britain protest causing an ambulance to
be delayed by nearly an hour on another
occasion with a chest pain emergency
another unnamed paramedic told the metro
newspaper that insulate britain were
causing ambulances to be called in
tailbacks created by the road blocking
protests when i read stories like this i
you know my blood boils i'm like what
what right have you got under the cause
of global warming and climate change
which you want to protect young people
in particular from a future which we
don't know that is going to be safe for
them to do this kind of thing where you
imperil people's lives or to stop a
child having an education or not being
able to get around or an old mum being
able to be driven around shopping i
don't think you have the right to play
god like that with people's lives yeah
and and i don't believe that this is a
cause
no no what we're talking about is a
physical reality yeah but it's also a
cause you're fighting a cause and you're
protesting there's the real world
protest about all sorts of things the
real world appears right and we need to
understand that we're living in the real
world i understand that what i don't
what i don't understand liam is why you
have to do the kind of things i've just
read out why you have to make that poor
woman not be able to take her son to
school there are other ways to protest
but why is that poor son in 20 years
time gonna live in a world that's one of
unimaginable horror
well we don't know where the world will
be in 20
this horrendous physical reality that
exists piers and we're not discussing it
well enough and cherylin's son is 11
years old doesn't get to have a say in
his future which at the current
trajectory is going to be one of
animations
i come back to the point i agree with
you about the need to take climate
change seriously what i don't agree with
you is stopping people from getting
emergency medical treatment or stopping
children going to school that to me
seems to be the opposite of what you're
trying to achieve which is a safer
future for people yes so what we're
saying here is why aren't we talking
about the government criminality that's
going on when every
person knows like this is happening now
we've got an absolutely catastrophic
heat wave going on in india and pakistan
at the moment to the point where
glaciers are melting in the himalayas
causing rivers to flood and breaking in
my point i don't disagree with you about
the dangers that are being faced to the
world i i would support you the problem
i have with your tactics is you put me
off supporting you you don't bring me to
your protest i don't think i want to
join these guys they're making a great
point i just look at this poor woman and
think why have you done that to her and
her kid i look at these terrible stories
of a woman left paralyzed because you
lot were lying in front of a car it's
like why do that there are other ways to
protest because you're not listening to
what i've just said you're not
emotionally connecting to the fact that
what i've just said to you is one
billion actually you're not listening to
what i'm saying no i am but what i'm
saying is we're in what you're not
hearing is i'm agreeing with your calls
with the campaign
i just don't agree with the tactics i
want you to concede but i don't agree
with government criminality to finish i
want you to concede that the tactics
you've been using are self-defeating i
think there's a better more effective
way to do it i think you would if you're
honest with yourself say that actually
this doesn't work this kind of thing it
might get you a few lyrid headlines but
i don't see any of the british public go
you know what i'm watching this video
i've got to join that protest they think
the opposite yeah i think you're a bunch
of people wrecking people's lives and i
don't think that's actually what you
want to achieve well look we're prepared
to take the consequences there's 14
people currently in prison non-violent
ordinary people that are currently in
prison ordinary people like cheryl and
speed are receiving unfair sentences
nobody wins here but what we're saying
is for the government look we've got all
we had an ordinary like a
no-brainer plan to insulate britain
which has been proven in an energy
crisis now i've got an energy bill with
550 pound that i'm really struggling to
pay i'm sure sherry do you enjoy that
you famously walked off good morning
britain and you're in good company all
the best people do yeah you walked off
good morning britain when they asked you
if you insulate your own home and you
said you don't because you're a
hypocrite have you started to insulate
it i just said to you i've got a 550
pound bill that i can't pay right so
just just to be clear though you still
don't insulate your own home even though
your whole campaign you've got to start
doing that so we're talking about social
housing i understand the poorest in our
society we're saying that it won't
happen unless the poorest in our society
can can do the job and as we all know
the poorest in our society are
struggling in poverty but i believe i
would take you more seriously if you did
insulate your own home so are you
and for the last 18 months i've been
doing a job that doesn't pay well peers
right so i'm not a very well-off guy and
what you're saying is that only people
that can afford ten thousand pounds to
insulate and retrofit
if you stop lying down in front of mums
trying to take their kids to school or
people whose mothers are literally
having strokes and getting paralyzed if
you stop doing that and you actually
practice what you preach about things
like installation people might be more
inclined to follow your campaign which
by the way just to finish on i agree
with we can come together we can come
let's get into the country
before we go
final question
do you have any sympathy with what he's
doing
sharon can you hear me
do you have any sympathy with lee yeah i
can hear you now do you have any
sympathy with liam
sympathy with him yeah
look i i just
look i spoke to liam i've said him
before i don't agree with the methods i
think we're stronger together
um i think that communication is key i
think that if we talk to people you know
if they come and speak come to our
communities and speak to us
you know maybe they would get more of us
on their side instead of pissing us off
and holding our cars and stuff i agree
i think we're reaching a little point
potential consensus here all right liam
you're on to the right idea you're
executing it in my view in a
self-harming way but we'll continue the
debate okay i'll promise you that
continue the debate good to talk to you
both thank you very much